one final bow for Aviation royalty the
very last 747 rolled off the assembly
line last week the jet has ruled the
commercial Airways since it debuted in
1969. the 747 once carried the space
shuttle and is credited with air travel
more accessible to the general public as
it takes off into the sunset Chris Van
Cleave has more on the plane and the
people who have spent Generations
building it
an event fit for the queen of the Skies
after more than five decades this is the
last brand new 747 that will ever be
built this is a pilot I know how great
this plane is to fly among those paying
tribute actor John Travolta there's
nothing like seeing a 747
take flight to remind you that there's
also magic here we visited Boeing's
Everett Washington plant as the plane
was in final assembly just days before
it rolled off the line made its first
test flight and was bathed in about 120
gallons of paint every time you finish a
job you know that it's going to be the
last time you do it and it just
kind of tugs at your heartstrings Sherry
mui built 747s for the last 15 years her
father started working on the same line
43 years ago my favorite thing about the
747 would just be that it's so iconic
that you see it in the sky you see it at
the airport you know exactly what that
is and it brings a lot of Pride knowing
that hey yes I helped build that it's
not just another airplane not just
another airplane the 747 was the world's
first jumbo jet twice as big as any
other airliner when it first flew back
in 1969. Pan Am will bring you the
world's first 747. Pan Am welcome to
First passengers on board a year later
with its spiral staircase first class
lounge and that iconic hump the 747 was
an instant hit this airplane marks the
point in history first time that any
person on planet Earth could get on an
airplane and fly it democratized air
travel absolutely because of its size
its range its economy now flight was
affordable
over more than 118 million flight hours
and counting its four engines have
carried millions of passengers six U.S
presidents and even the space shuttle
across the country and around the world
after building
1574 747s this marks the end of the line
for the queen of the Skies but for the
thousands of people here in Everett who
work on the airplane it really marks the
beginning of a new chapter they are all
going on to new jobs on other lines
building new airplanes that'll be flying
for decades to come while those newer
more fuel-efficient planes are bringing
about the end of this Queen's Reign
especially as a passenger plane the
final 747 a freighter will likely be
delivering goods for years to come
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Chris Van
Cleave in Everett Washington
and taking over for the 747 is the 777 x
which is just about the same size is it
actually but just more fuel efficient
and a better plane yeah you know the 7
of it was just
of my
Hood
like being on them was just thrilling
seeing some of those old shots just made
me think of some of those really old
school things and the thing we always
say like when people used to dress up to
go and all of them yeah